I moved home to Singapore about 2 years ago from the US.
One of the biggest reasons why I decided
to move home was to spend more time with my mom.
That was about the same time that I met my co-founder Lily as well.
Both of us were at the stage of our lives
where we were spending more time with
our aged parents and in-laws.
We want to build a solution that provides quality home care
to enable independent living at home.
We felt that we could combine Lily’s background in health care
and my background in business and technology
and create this improved experience within the home care space.
When our seniors are not well
they would not want to check themselves into the hospital
and lose the control of their lives.
All of them want to be cared for at home.
Homage app creates the accessibility
to people who needs care for themselves and for their loved ones.
My work start at 9 o’clock and end at 6.30
so my mom will be alone during my office hours.
She told me that she cannot take care of herself
like bathing, clothing and simple cooking.
Calie was selected from Homage to be a care pro for my mom.
She’s very friendly and she told me
‘No worry, you can just go to work and I will take care of her’.
Calie also took some pictures
so I know what she has done for my mom
It’s very convenient.
At anytime, anywhere - I can know what’s going on.
So the Start on Android program really made
a huge difference in our mobile app development.
They were invested in our growth, in the experience we were providing our users.
Every single discussion was anchored around
how can we improve this experience
Whether it’s in material design, in UI/UX.
They have been helping us look at it from a user’s perspective.
One of the key outcomes of being part of the Start On Android program
is that we got featured on the Play Store recently.
It’s been so great to have this support of not just having a great team but also
members within the tech community like Google Play.
I would absolutely recommend the Start on Android program to other startups.
A lot of the value is in just getting external feedback.
Often times you can develop in a vacuum
and just having skilled experts tell you
“these are the areas that you need to improve on”
you can really fast track the way you deliver these improvements to your users.
Our aspiration is to build a huge community of caregivers
who are trained and happy to help anyone.
With our Homage app, help will just be a click away.
All these seniors can age in confidence knowing that
there’s always help around for them.